opinion
what's your opinion what's your opinion
you're the one holding the sign i want
your right my opinion's on the side
you're open you're on the side yeah
abortion
yeah
agree or disagree i agree you agree you
think abortion is uh
why yeah why because because women use
it as a cop-out for the poor decisions
that they made the poor decisions they
make what's the poor decisions well they
shouldn't have been sleeping with
someone that's not a good father no
that's not necessarily about the father
what's the father got to do if it's sure
if it's a woman's decision well because
you need someone to raise the kid with
right so i'm saying it's a cop-out for
making a poor decision
well i think he's ready to be a follower
we're not using an iud not using a
condom not using the 10 forms of birth
control that we have to choose from so
you're being irresponsible and you're
using abortion as a cop a woman that uh
doesn't contraception doesn't really
work with her it makes her it makes her
i don't know makes her bleed inside or
for example a dietary plans or whatever
where you think it's a co-op because she
had sex and unfortunately got pregnant
what about condom i mean the guy's like
ice choice no well i get to pick who i
sleep with and i and i can and i can so
if i was gonna sleep with someone i
could require them to wear a condom
that's my choice and if he chooses not
to and then you end up getting pregnant
you think having an abortion from that
point is a cop out so so i really try to
stay away from exceptions rather than
the rule right and and and so if i don't
consent if i don't wait in an argument
like this you can't stay away from
exception so less than one percent of
abortions are in the case under the case
of grapes so forty less than one percent
and forty percent of women that get
abortions have had two or more abortions
so that's that's to me indicating it's
just poor decision making i don't think
it's poor decision maker and i feel like
it's women that are in a point of time
where they're not ready to to be a
mother uh they are in a relationship
that might not be perfect for them to
have children i don't think it's a
cop-out i think it's it's a decision
that women should be allowed to make for
themselves i never understand guys that
support abortion why would you want your
girl to kill your kid
that's your kid i don't get it but you
know i guess you know to each his own so
so what i'm saying is that the data
indicates that it is a cop-out because
again it's not making a briefing i'm
gonna lie
so so i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying
that they're making a poor decision of
who to sleep with i don't know you don't
think women should be selective with who
they sleep with
nah i mean i mean yes and no we are kind
of like are you in the street whoa
21st century you have the freedom to you
have the freedom to be so we have the
freedom to do abstinence too anyways
back to the point that you made um
towards um the data suggests i can't lie
when it comes to data it's completely
just the topic football when you look at
football they are if you analyze
football football of data you will get
the wrong information when it comes to
players if you analyze life based solely
of data you're going to get the wrong
you're not going to understand the human
life like how people behave choices
within life decisions timing all of that
counts into it so what do you think we
should draw conclusions based on if
we're not using data draw our
conclusions it's hard to draw
conclusions just freely they are yeah
cool it is nice to draw it is nice to
have an opinion using data however
drawing conclusions just based off they
i don't agree so i think it's hard to
have discussions with people that don't
draw any conclusions based on data
because then it's just how we feel life
is about how you feel though no no it's
the policy is based off of data life is
about how you feel it's about you make
you make decisions on based on how you
feel now do you think that we should
make policy based on how people feel um
policies policies based on how people
feel yeah yeah going on this logic no no
i can't lie no okay so it has to be
awesome yeah i like backtracking all my
statements so it has to be based on data
give me a second you were ready for this
argument i wasn't it's okay i'm not i'm
not trying to i don't edit this out so
they'll see it should we make policies
based on data i think i think if we
basically only make policies based on
they are we're really treading on a thin
line based on on what data just suggests
in my opinion okay what's the thin line
i feel like if we're basing if we're
just um like i'm gonna have to scramble
in my head now and think for example
i can't get i can't think of an example
this is a bad argument i've set myself
into because i'm not actually ready for
it no because my my whole point is like
a lot of times we bring up exceptions
and say oh there's all these far off
reasons that women get abortions right
but typically in my experience the woman
just isn't being responsible we have all
these different forms of birth control
that we can use like we can if you get a
you call it the coil here you have a 99
plus chance of getting pregnant there's
no hormones in that of not getting
pregnant so it seems like it's just a
fail-safe and a cop-out for poor
decision
no it's not i don't say it's a cop-out
because you might not be in a position
that you're ready to have to be a mother
there's not like you have the freedom to
live the life that you want and there
obviously choices that people can then
make afterwards if they do get pregnant
to obviously eliminate that factor i
don't think it's it's not do you think
if you're not ready to be a mother maybe
you should take steps to have
precautions before you have sex yeah of
course i understand punishment
it seems like women aren't doing that
because forty percent of women have had
two or more abortions that get abortions
sixty percent that get them in the
future so you don't actually know what
person so sorry refresh me on the
statement that you made originally
because i had to go off from it from the
abortion is a cop-out that's the
original no no no from the little
statement that you just made now say for
example a woman makes it not necessarily
a mistake but she gets end up getting
pregnant and she's not in a position
that she wants to be a mother do you
feel like she doesn't have the right to
make a decision to be a mother or not i
would say now when you get pregnant it's
a unique dna sequence that's different
from the mother and the father if we're
going to believe the science 95 percent
of scientists say that life begins at
conception when it's still a cell and it
hasn't actually grown into anything you
think it's the sperm and the egg meat
remember it has a unique dna code that's
different from the mother and the father
it's not just the cell so that you that
dna code has what the kids eye color is
going to be their hair color their
personality traits and and that's
completely different from the mothers
and the fathers and if we're going to
use the bot the argument that i hear a
lot my body my choice would you say that
they can a day before they give birth
have a have an abortion a day before
because it's in my body accuracy then
you see i think it's an america are you
american yes it's the plan b the one
after bill would you say that you are
against that completely i actually don't
know enough about plan b to have an
opinion you're saying it from no i i
don't know so like so when the egg is
then fertilized you would then obviously
have an issue with plan b as well
because if that's the case again i'm not
going to make a statement that i don't i
don't i base my i base my opinions on
facts so so i don't i don't know enough
about plan b to have an opinion on it
well i'm not very well equipped enough
with stats or data to have this argument
with you you're very ready still clearly
standing shortage for an argument
okay well thank you i really i really
appreciate i really appreciate talking
to people that disagree so i thank you
for having me enough i'm not ready for
this okay i don't i don't expect people
to be so it's like i you hope so but i
don't think it's a cop-out i feel like
if you have the if we have the um the
abilities the abilities to have an
abortion
the freedom you have the freedom of
choice to choose so yeah that's my
opinion known towards it it's like if
you have if you have something on sale
and it's not illegal and it's legal to
do so
then by all means usually
i'm just curious so at what point should
women be able to get abortions up to i
think life begins at birth so you would
you would support an abortion if i got
an abortion the week before the kid was
born well that's never going to happen
that doesn't happen right it does happen
something's gonna happen abortion before
a week before the child was born they're
what they're putting okay okay let's
let's let's do two months two months
before that doesn't happen either most
abortions are way before that so i'm
gonna give you a stat okay so in the uk
in the uk abortions are legal up to 24
weeks
the earliest pregnancy to survive is 21
weeks okay so do you not see a problem
with that when the kid could survive
without the money
what's the percentage that happens
the percentage
i i'm not sure off the top of my head
doesn't because again we're talking
about the legality so i'm asking you
should that be and then what happens in
reality so there's
there's the legal and then the reality
of the life i don't see i don't imagine
or see any woman having an abortion at
21 weeks even if it's legal and free i
could look it up i don't want to
misquote it i want to say it's around 20
percent i'm 20 i mean your base your
arguments are facts so you can't bring
that in there unless you believe that's
you can't argue that women aren't doing
it if you don't if you don't have any
data to back that up but i'm saying i'm
100 sure it's legal and free up to 24
weeks
so so i'm saying should it be should it
be legal but i'm asking you a question
should it be legal at 21. so at 21 weeks
that's the earliest pregnancy that's
survived should it be legal at 24. under
my argument that life begins at birth
yeah 100
okay well at least you're consistent
if you choose at like um 21 weeks where
it's still legal to have an abortion
then by all means do so up it to seven
months would that be cool but they
wouldn't do that though it could if you
could tell me your country or where it's
ever happened that seven months then
then we would have a conversation if if
i if i found you one would you change
your i mean run right now in a country
where you can get an abortion at seven
months then we can have an argument in
the u.s they have some laws that you
care
some laws is that factual no it's not an
opinion it's i i'm positive yeah yeah
because there was a really big
in the uk aren't we frank goodwin you
just you just moved the goal post
together you said if you could if you
could find me something i'm in the uk
i'm arguing for uk faculty so then when
i ask you should i add 24 weeks oh this
argument why am i still here 24 weeks
that's the question i keep asking you do
you keep moving the goalpost no
the same argument 21 if it's legal at 24
weeks 24 weeks off my top of my head
still six months then yeah but if it's
legal by law then yeah why not okay and
even though a kid can survive at 21. i
mean if the law makes it legal at 24
weeks then by all means okay well thank
you the argument that life begins at
birth in my opinion
yeah okay okay thank you for stopping